and what we've seen happen within the
Marvel Universe is this ever-expanding
coterie of superheroes and I think now
we're at the stage where this universe
even within our world is God's quite
crowded and it's just about to explode
into other dimensions I was shown my
legacy at the end of the path I started
us on everyone has their favorite Marvel
movie and everyone has a favorite Marvel
world and just to see all of them coming
together it's a daring act you guys
every story that Marvel has told since
Iron Man one finds a narrative thread in
these next two Avengers movies it is a
culmination of all of that storytelling
with infinity war we are paying off
every little thread and every little
tease that we've had in what will be 18
films prior to infinity war there's
never been anything like this
being able to film after film teased at
a larger story really building these
stories up into a giant conclusion while
at the same time introducing an entirely
new direction for the future
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie I've been
getting a lot of requests to do a video
for the Disney Fox deal because Comcast
looked like it was gonna swoop in and
steal all the Fox stuff from Disney but
then Disney came back with a whole dump
truck of money so I'll explain what's
going on with the deal what the timeline
is and when we'll actually get to start
seeing x-men and Fantastic Four
characters show up in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe movies if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
we're just getting ramped up for ant-man
and the wasp but there's gonna be more
Avengers force stuff happening soon that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway is still
going on all you have to do tend to that
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video I'll name a new winner at
the end of this the latest in the
billion dollar slap fight between Disney
and Comcast over the Fox assets is that
originally Disney had offered about
fifty two billion dollars in stock to
Fox they'd accepted it they're like okay
there's a certain timeline for our deal
will have a shareholders meeting in July
we'll discuss how to proceed if
regulators try to shut us down because
the government still has to approve the
deal even though Fox really does want to
sell to Disney that a little while ago
everybody heard about Comcast's swooping
in and offering 65 billion dollars in
cash like straight cash passing a bag of
money across the table for all that Fox
stuff because they really wanted the sky
networks so if you don't know those are
broadcasters largely in the UK they just
wanted like parts of Fox they don't care
about Fantastic Four they don't care
about x-men any of that stuff they just
want a couple big unrelated pieces of
Fox
so people were waiting for Disney to
come back with another offer they did by
upping their bid to Fox 471 billion
dollars which included their original
stock deal in a bunch of extra cash on
top of that to make up the difference so
Disney really really wants Fox in Fox
really really wants to sell to Disney
Rupert Murdoch mr. Fox himself really
loves the idea of the Disney deal
worst-case scenario what would have
happened is is comcast would have won
the deal and Disney was just made of
arrangements with them to get some of
their IP back the Marvel stuff is why
this is getting all the attention but
Disney wants to be able to compete with
Netflix because it's rolling out its own
streaming service so if you own all the
pre
mium content then it just incentivizes
people to sign up for your service so
that is the way the Disney fights
Netflix they say we have all the best
content that people want we have all
Disney all Pixar all Marvel all the Fox
stuff now so was just a bonus on top of
that that Kevin Feige will get to put
x-men in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
characters now I say Fantastic Four to
is a slightly separate thing with
Fantastic Four because a different
studio besides Fox owns the rights to
that but if all the Fox x-men stuff is
going to be going to Disney then of
course the studio that owns Fantastic
Four is gonna broker a deal with Kevin
Feige the same way that Sony brokered a
deal for spider-man
what is looking like is going to happen
right now is is that the government will
approve the deal shortly they said that
they're expecting that to happen earlier
than they thought before and that's also
one of the reasons why Rupert Murdoch
really wanted to sell Fox to Disney
before Comcast swooped in they said that
the dust from the deal was going to be
settling by the end of next summer now
that's after they had already dropped
the second spider-man homecoming film
meaning that any chance of x-men
characters or Fantastic Four popping up
in Marvel Cinematic Universe movies
won't happen till the movies that start
after guardians of the galaxy 3 so James
Gunn was also asked about this - like if
they get x-men will you put x-men
characters in guardians 3 and he said
that he's too far along and development
to change that on a fundamental level so
don't expect big x-men characters in
guardians 3 right now that movies
scheduled for spring 2020 release so
anything after that is fair game in
terms of x-men characters in Marvel
Cinematic Universe movies but now of
course you're asking which characters
are gonna be first this is gonna be
fantastic for or is it gonna be x-men
what about Wolverine what are they gonna
start recasting people what is it gonna
look like is it gonna be a separate
universe or are they just gonna waltz
into the Avengers building in Avengers 5
and say well we've been mutants this
whole time we've been around for all
these big conflicts we were just hiding
out we didn't want to tell people we
existed what I'm expecting based on the
way Kevin Feige operates in the way they
introduce brand-new huge characters in
MCU movies is it'll be a civil war
spider-man situation where somebody says
I know a guy and then that guy just
happens to be Reed Richards of the
Fantastic
stick for we're seriously understaffed
oh yeah where's yours downstairs where's
yours so they'll introduce one character
first and then in the next movie they'll
introduce a whole bunch more like
spider-man and black panther were
introduced during Civil War you got a
taste for what their abilities were what
they look like then you got spider-man
homecoming and black panther and you got
the deep dive into their characters so
you'd probably see a mixture of thor
ragnarok style crossovers where you get
like one character crossing over with a
pre-existing MCU character in thier
movie then like a genuine spin-off
fantastic for MCU or x-men MCU movie
with recast characters so as you go
without saying I do expect them to
recast a lot of big roles like when we
get a new Reed Richards of course it's
gonna have to be a recast role the only
characters that I think that they will
leave untouched will be Deadpool and his
characters because it's so meta and so
different from the tone of what Marvel
is doing in the cinematic universe but I
think Kevin Feige will do is he'll just
loan out MCU characters that he's not
using to the Deadpool movies like
juggernaut showed up in Deadpool 2 they
hadn't been using him in the x-men
movies in a long long time there's a lot
of time-travel speculation in Avengers 4
I think what they'll be doing is is when
they fix the universe they'll just leave
room to explain how you have all these
new ideas because they're supposed to be
some Eternals popping up in Avengers 4
and the Eternals is sort of them hedging
their bets if they don't get the x-men
characters but now that the deal looks
like it's gonna go through they'll
proceed with the Eternals movie but
they'll gain access to all the other
x-men space-based ip2 so what will
happen is is we get more news about the
Disney deal I'll do updates but it's
still looking like it's gonna be next
year before everything is done and it's
gonna be after guardians 3 before you
see any kind of crossover between these
two universes but before that happens
Fox is still making movies so we're
gonna still get that Deadpool x-force
movie we're still gonna get dark Phoenix
will still get new mutants so there's
still be a lot of Fox stuff happening
before we see MCU Fox stuff happening
there were
whole bunch of Avengers infinity war
behind-the-scenes videos that just
dropped I'll do a video for that next be
sure to check out Luke Cage I'll be
doing a non-spoilery Luke Cage video
this weekend you may have just seen Sony
also just announced that they're
developing a Cindy moon silk spider-man
movie so we'll try to dig up some more
information and do a video about that
sometime this weekend so more Spider Man
coming this weekend and I'll say
congratulations to Russell Sanders
please private message me so I can get
your contact details while you wait for
everything click here for that
spider-man iron spider scene and click
here for that other Avengers for Kevin
Feige teaser thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you